so God's upset because he made man on
earth and it grieved him at his heart
and God says I will destroy man whom I
have created from the face of the earth
both man and beast and the creeping
thing and the fowls of the air for I
repent that I've made them but Noah
found grace in the eyes of the Lord okay
so that's an interesting thing so here
what we have is the question is the
whole worlds in chaos at this point
right in this point the story and the
chaos is of multiple sorts it arose from
the fall it rose from the emergence of
self-consciousness it emerged safe arose
from the sins of Cain like things are
not going well it's multiple levels of
collapse and it's got to the point where
God saying this is a mess like it's such
a mess that the whole thing has to be
washed away the first fall wasn't enough
even Cain's collapse wasn't enough we're
going to just scrub the whole bloody
thing clean so it's it's the ultimate in
traumatic collapses the question is well
what do you do in the face of the
ultimate in traumatic collapses and the
answer is in the story so Noah as
someone who finds fate who finds favor
in the eyes of God so he's like Abel
there's something that Noah's doing
right it's going to enable him to ride
out the storm and so the question hits
the same question do you want to have a
life where there's no storms or do you
want to have a life where you can ride
out the storms that's the issue right
are you behind the dykes or do you build
a boat do you captain the boat that's
the same idea and so the idea here is
that the thing that rides out the chaos
is the thing that builds and captain's
the boat it's another dominance
hierarchy idea what should be at the top
well it's it's the top of something that
doesn't get flooded out as well what
should be at the top well it's to be the
boat builder and to be the captain of
the boat it's not to be hidden from the
flood precisely and so I mean here's a
here's here's something to think about
identity identity politics because
that's what we're up to our neck it okay
are you who you are
can i box you in will you accept that as
an identity so I could do that lots of
ways you're male you're Asian you're
young right there's things about you
that I can derive
because of your putative membership in a
set of different groups the problem with
doing that is that the number of groups
that I can assign you to is without end
so I have to pick arbitrary groups to
assign you to and you can accept that if
you want but there's no evidence that
those are the proper canonical groups
but maybe you're happy about that
because now you've been assigned
membership in a group and that's your
identity okay so the question is well
fine what happens when that identity is
flown into pieces then what well here's
here's the answer to some degree and
this is the answer that's embedded in
the story of Noah if you wanted
withstand chaos do you want to be who
you are or do you want to be the thing
that changes who you are constantly
that's the question and that's the
difference that's the difference there's
a categorical difference in identity are
you who you are
or are you the thing that could
continually be more than you are and
that's the thing that isn't the stable
identity it's not the initial state it's
also not the state of being in chaos
that nihilistic state let's say and it's
not even the state of reformulations
that occurs after you've gone through
the process it's the state of
continually going through the process so
you can identify with the thing that
trends you can identify identify with
the thing that you are or you can
identify with the thing that transforms
who you are right and that's the same as
the state subjugating itself to the
individual because the individual is the
thing that transforms the state and what
the state should do the states necessary
because obviously it organizes all of us
into peaceful cooperation and
competition the states necessary then
the question is is the state the highest
good and the answer that is well it
can't be because it's old and dead and
blind and so if the state becomes the
highest good then you're occupied by the
spirit of something that's old and dead
and blind well that's not only not good
for you because then you're old and dead
and blind but it's also bad for the
state because as soon as the state gets
old and dead and blind God gets unhappy
with it and the chaos comes in
washes it away so it seems like a bad
solution so what's the proper solution
you subordinate your group identity to
the identity that transforms your
identity right and the state
subordinates its power to the vision and
articulation of the individual because
that's what revives the state and so
that's what these stories are trying to
stumble towards roughly speaking